ochio tomahto leggy and Rachel shall be
the author of we look like the enemy the
hidden story of is for else Jews from
Arab lands welcome to you both
Rachel you first Hamas who invented it
well it's a two-fold question because
you could say that you know a lot of
people think the Ottomans invented it in
which case everyone who lived under
Ottoman rule can lay claim to it and
that includes Jews and that includes
Jews who lived in what was then historic
Palestine but on the other hand to me
what really gives the game away what
gives Israel's claim the lie the tell if
you like is the fact that Israelis are
so obsessive about homeless that they
actually treat it as a main course like
they end up having hummus for lunch
which for everybody else in the Middle
East and also Palestinians who end up
having to watch this and also serve it
they're like what are you doing hummus
is homeless isn't the main event it's an
appetizer you know obviously the main
event is the meat so to me that's what
really gives away Israel's kind of bogus
claim to owners of the after seasons not
only did they're not invented they eat
it wrong I think I think there is a lot
of bit parallel histories to this food I
mean there's some some writers claims
that it's you they can read about Hamas
in the Old Testament so Jews in
Palestine or
have eaten something that is you know
you know you never know because it's not
called homeless it's called someone or
something else so the release go on
going to bed who ate it first but this
debate on who it is first is very hard
difficult to solve because nobody knows
when it's actually being put together
and you say the Ottomans some people say
it's bit earlier than thank God yeah
some people say it's gone which I guess
that's the best solution but there's
also not as an argument about who makes
it the best and that's another thing I
mean what it's the best hummus
restaurant in Israel in Lebanon and
those are really really match or
arguments or does it conducted between
men they sit around a big table they eat
homos you know you they wipe it with the
pizza and there are he was the best
homeless to have so I think this is
actually quite a good way to argument
about to argue about politics because
everybody like homeless so you can kind
of take the political argument and you
know I think the political argument is
unfortunately inherent in the comas I
mean if only we could you know live in
the world where the politics wasn't part
of the homeless you know I guess the
Lebanese will probably lay stake to the
best homeless at the moment but there
are there are Palestinian places inside
is Iran itself and also in occupied
parts I mean my Cameron was just saying
it best obvious he had was in Nigeria
but made by Lebanese do you think you
get the best of us well I haven't been
to Lebanon but I think there for me it's
all about what you do with the homeless
so you know I come and I come to it is
from chefs percepts perspective so you
don't you don't play mess around with me
with it's for me ho Moses jek peace
tahini lemon juice and garlic and some
people start adding all sorts of things
beetroot or also it's a pure thing you
know I feel very strongly about it and
does it have to because some of that I
don't like the chickpeas for Holi
no super smooth but the chickpeas are
garnish which is something that is very
popular both we Lebanese and Israelis
and Palestinians and they're Damien's N
and then Egyptians I mean some people
still claim that it actually started in
Egypt and the Egyptians eat hummus with
dried broad beans on top fava beans or
full and it's eaten in other parts of
the Middle East and its depth salutely
delicious and the ingredients have they
always been there or did any of them
come from the new world no I mean those
those ingredients are classic the ones
that your tongue just mentioned you
wouldn't want to put anything else in
the homeless first of all that would
totally show you up as a fake but
secondly it would completely it would
completely ruin the dish but I think you
know apartment apart from the politics
you know the reason that homeless it's
so important that we're having these
kind of homeless Wars is that it's about
food and it's in the Middle East so you
know of course to certain extent taking
over the world knows that I mean yeah
absolutely I mean it is the most the
best-selling dip in the Western world I
mean by far you know you know well it
was cold slower
well things that come from a little and
that's things it's carbonate are burning
in the
in the supermarket and this is exactly
what how homeless is not eaten in the
Middle East I mean people don't
understand it actually homo Caesar is a
meal or part of a meze but it's never
refrigerated and eat that comes from the
fridge and that's one of the
misconception when people come for the
first time to to Palestine to Israel to
Lebanon they're absolutely shocked to
see how it served as a dish on its with
its own kind of sense of identity
whether in the selection of meze or
serve warm with lamb on top or whole
chickpeas or falafel on top it's a whole
ceremony so this is why people feel so
strongly about it it's a it's a bit like
the equivalent here would be a potato or
bread it's a staple and the staple means
that everybody feels very strongly about
it I mean how you should cook it how you
sure you should eat it how do you think
I think you should eat it definitely not
as a main course just you know as an
appetizer no no I'm a fundamentalist
about a ureter and I think you should
just have it on its own maybe with a
bait really good a bit of really good
olive oil and paprika over the top but
that's it don't mess with the whole I
don't see that way and the top should
people be making it for themselves
yeah well the top tip is that you really
need to use fresh chickpeas not canned
chickpeas because many recipes call for
the short cut but you really need to
soak your own chickpeas and then make it
from fresh chickpeas okay now wars here
thank you very very much indeed